welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul and it looks like
what happens in las vegas is gonna stay
in las vegas as our heroes back home
still have no idea what's going on
the fifth episode has just released and
it's it's a weird one isn't it it's a
weird one
now i'd actually been watching advanced
reviews of the season to gauge people's
thoughts on it
and they all said that this is where the
show went completely off the rails
i kind of agree to some extent but we're
going to be talking about it in the
video
now if you've been enjoying the coverage
so far then i'd massively appreciate it
if you hit the thumbs up button
as it helps me to help you digest what
we've just watched
if you're still not subscribed to the
channel then make sure you do as we're
going to be doing
in-depth one division breakdowns
starting from tomorrow and you
definitely don't want to miss them
anyway episode 5 picks up with dana
jurgens who successfully infiltrated
rhino flag's operation
in the city of sin the time jumps are
pretty much missing from this entry
and instead we get quite a
straightforward story which travels from
place to place
rather than backwards and forwards
through time working undercover as an
engineer on the hoover dam
dana picks up the attention of julie
lowry after asking too many
questions about randall flagg now if
you've read the book then you'll know
similar to what we see in the show
in order to speak to him she has to go
through his right hand man lloyd
who we see has been living in what he
classes as heaven
hey looks better than most of the things
i've heard from people who went on
holiday to vegas anyway
lloyd states that he rides the elevator
all the way to the top
which typically means that someone has
access to everything
but in this episode it's literal as we
learn that flag lives on a penthouse
floor which overlooks the city
now the journey that dana goes on in the
episode differs slightly from what's
laid out in the book
and she actually sleeps with lloyd in
order to reach the devil man
now though dana was willing to go ahead
with the deed she's saved by julie
however it does hint towards how
dedicated she is to this mission
had me saying damn i don't mean the
hoover one hey you having that
now after getting a good look over the
abandoned city we can see tom cullen
riding in on his bike from last week
i don't know if mike is the correct term
but he's almost placed into the slave
cages before being saved by one of the
bouncers
we learned that a real witch flag has is
that anyone who comes to the city
voluntarily cannot be forced into this
and it also lets us certainly know that
they have been capturing people and
taking them there
not everyone is lucky enough to live
with the survivors and therefore it
hints towards the darker side of the
city
now juxtaposing that more sinister side
when we see las vegas from dana's
perspective
it looks like the kind of place that
would get you instantly demonetized on
youtube
if you showed any of it sounds like my
kind of monday
but it's clear that the character is
definitely disgusted by it all
elsewhere nadine and harold are
destroying their clothes from last week
after the pair were complicit in the
murder of teddy they make it look like
he took his own life
and since no one is part of csi miami
they buy this story that he shot himself
in the heart
seems pretty stupid but larry suspects
that something else is afoot
and this eventually leads him to start
taking a closer look at harold
now harold himself actually hints
towards a big change from the source
material
when he talks about showcasing some of
the movies that teddy collected
in the original work the plan to plant
the explosives was actually at a
completely different location
which i don't want to spoil just in case
it goes back to that
but it does seem here that he's gonna be
doing it at the cinema event
which is teased at in this moment that's
just a theory and the plan could of
course
change but i actually appreciate how
they set up the cinema motif with freddy
which then could of course become a
place that harold ends up attacking
now another diversion from the source
material comes when abigail lambast
nick for sending out spies in the book
she actually left before finding this
out
and they did alter things quite a lot
originally abigail believed that she had
sinned by being proud
and went into the wilderness on a
journey similar to what jesus did in the
bible
this absence made the committee decide
to send in spies
but here they actually add motive to why
she's so afraid
towards the end of the entry she's
confronted by a wolf which is of course
the symbol of randall flagg
and then flees showing that she may have
even been scared of what's to come
i'm not that religious but if i knew for
definite that god was talking to me
then i probably would have held off
until he said to do anything
it's a bit weird to me that nick was her
voice and disobeyed her
but it does tie more into this general
bible aesthetic
abigail discusses how the israelites
sent spies which led to them being in
the desert for 40 years
and this of course intersects really
well with the desert city of las vegas
after avoiding a bit of romance with
julian lloyd the latter of which i think
is wearing a michael jackson jacket
dana notices tom working as someone that
clears up bodies in the gladiator pit
julie recognizes him which is very
significant for things going ahead
and flag is of course looking out for
the spies amongst his ranks
but i think because of his mental
capabilities that he's not had his mind
read
now we can see firsthand that flag can
levitate and he's worshipped as a god by
his followers
a creepy moment comes when he looks
directly at dana whilst we can still
hear his voice in the background
and though i would have got the hell out
of there she still continues her mission
he overlooks everything in an almost
crucifixion pose
and i think the character's design in
general is meant to be similar to jesus
to show us that he is indeed the
antichrist he reaches out to nadine who
is she pooing in the bed never mind
nadine who's scorned by a flag offering
her to harold
and she really goes on a journey in this
episode and seems to want to free
herself from his control
now throughout the episode we learned
that in order to do this she must lose
her virginity
throughout the breakdown she discussed
how the character promised herself the
flag
and how he has used this to manipulate
her thus
she throws herself at harold in order to
escape
harold dodges a bullet and lets one go
in his pants and like last week i bet
the guy is glad he didn't get into that
one
not long after he's invited to a meal
with fran and stew
so that the former can spy on him i was
actually thinking that fran
might just be being a nice person but it
turns out
she's really not they kind of paint her
out in a different light in this episode
as we see how much she cares about her
image and being perceived as someone
that's very kind
harold tells a story that used to float
around their town when she was younger
about how she gave him an ice cream once
but we discovered that it never actually
happened
this story has been told so many times
that fran actually believes it
and it shows harold as being more of a
victim who's been used so that she can
seem good
clearly because of all the things he did
for her on the road he's been starting
to see her as someone who isn't as
angelic as he thought
and this does tie into why he might take
the path he does
it definitely shows her in another way
and we see this murder nadine who has a
change of heart after meeting mother
abigail
unlike flag she's very open and this is
shown in her piano which she leaves the
top of
so that kids can see the strings in
fiction strings are often used as a
symbol of someone puppeting other people
but the fact that abigail has these out
in the open cements that
even though she is slightly controlling
she's open and honest about it
this is the complete opposite to flag
who traditionally appears playing card
games
as we all know when you play chords you
tend to hide your hand
so this hints to us that we don't really
know what he's doing
he holds all the cards whereas abigail
wants to work with people and show them
what's going on
and it's a really subtle thing that adds
a lot of subtext to the show
after telling nadine she has a choice
nadine goes to larry
and asks him to sleep with her he of
course can't because he has a mission
and probably because he's been reading
the daily mail now this is different to
the book
as in that larry was in a relationship
with lucy swann
who has been completely cut from the
mini-series he plays it off
as being something that's better for joe
if they just stay as parental figures
for him
but clearly she's bummed out and does
some of the best acting that
i've ever actually seen from her you
very much
now across town larry breaks into
harold's home
and you might recognize the music in the
background as it was actually used as a
theme tune for netflix's show dark
shout out to all the people who watch my
breakdowns on that i miss you guys now
in the home he finds the tom cruise
mirror which
it is a bit weird now i think about it i
should probably take mine down too
and also i kind of wonder why why they
keep doing this in the show
and i do have a theory that that they
actually put this photo up so that they
could say tom cruise featured in five
episodes or something
i also wonder if they have to use to pay
his image but we're getting off track
we are but let me know what you think in
the comments below now similar to larry
snooping around
harold places a camera in fran and
stew's bedroom so that he can spy on
them
and he makes an excuse and leaves larry
discovers nadine's t-shirt in his straw
and harold realizes that someone has
been going through his home after a
chess piece is slightly out of place
dana manages to get past the bouncer in
vegas and she meets tom to give him a
note
that says run this was actually said to
her by flag when he stared at her
and hopefully her death which comes next
actually spurs him on to go home
now i might be misremembering this as i
read this story a while back
but i'm sure that dana didn't meet with
tom and i don't even remember her
knowing who he was
i think they sent the spies in without
telling them he was who so that they
wouldn't compromise one another
but clearly she does know who he is now
in the work
i think she did recognize him eventually
but i don't remember anything about a
note being passed however let me know
below now
the scene in which she attempts to take
flag out differs slightly
as in that she originally took in a
spring-loaded knife
which flag turned into a banana maybe
that was too close to that bitten
infinity war for them to do
so instead she stabs him in the neck
which doesn't actually work
flag tells her that he will send her
home and divulges that he knows judge
varys is on the outskirts of town
which will likely be a big scene that we
see play out next time
knowing that he will torture her until
she gives up the others
she ends her own life and in the
original work flag was
furious about this and kicked the crap
out of her body
he then ordered lloyd to dispose of it
and he cremated the corpse
stating that he was burning trash cutter
fran and stew getting it on
and though she's heavily pregnant a man
james marsden
doesn't mess about harold watches over
this and stew doing the deed is pretty
much the polar opposite to how he was
with her
in episode 1 we learned that harold
spied on fran threw a hole in the fence
and this scene very much feels like an
extension of that
through it he learns that larry was
indeed in his home
and everything is interrupted when we
learn that mother abigail has
disappeared
which ends the episode now on the whole
i found this
entry a bit jarring tonally and some of
the scenes in las vegas
were just such a big shift that it felt
almost neck breaking at points
i am still interested in the series and
there's actually only three episodes
left of the main storyline
before we go into the final episode
which contains king's new ending
it's going to be interesting to see if
they can fit the rest of the plot into
it
and pull it off successfully but i'd of
course love to hear your thoughts on the
season so far
and if you're still on board or not as a
thank you for interacting with the video
you'll be entered into a prize draw
where we're giving away three copies of
the hobbit and lord of the rings 4k box
set to our subscribers
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the episode the links to our
socials are in the description
and you can also support the channel by
clicking the join button and as
a thank you you get videos like this
early if you want something else to
watch then make sure you check out our
breakdown of the previous episode which
will be linked on screen right now
we go through the entire thing so it's
definitely worth watching if you need a
catch up
or if you just missed it in general and
want to hear more of my annoying voice
without the way thank you for sticking
through the video i've been paul i'll
see you next time
take care peace